Lieutenant Chris Olivares the Texas
Department of Public Safety he's right
there on the front line with us and
Chris we're always talking on these
developments and I was thinking maybe
the fact that more Democrats are
speaking out about this that might offer
some hope for you what do you think
I mean I think that we've reached that
Breaking Point already with this current
border crisis they quite frankly we
reached it ever since last year and now
we're starting to see more
um you know you know political figures
that are coming forward and voicing
concerns that enough is enough and it is
I mean it's unacceptable what's been
taking place ever since last year now
that even going into this fiscal year
now we're still continuing to see large
groups come across human smugging events
and the fact that these border
committees are overwhelmed they want
they want something done they want a
strategy put in place by the federal
government they want them to take action
and they have completely neglected the
American people the people that reside
in these border communities they have
turned their backs on them and they feel
they feel abandoned and that's why the
state of Texas having to step in and
fill those gaps where federal agents are
tied up processing because they're not
getting the support from the federal
government so and it's it's unfortunate
but unfortunately we're going to
continue seeing this this Mass migration
take place you know throughout the
southern border until the federal
government actually puts some action in
place and so they actually address and
acknowledge the fact that we do have a
crisis on the border you know um you
were the first to season the fact when
these cases would no longer be
adjudicated back in Mexico in other
words someone slipped over the Border
went back to Mexico and dealt with it on
that side now of course the rolled out
here and they all become Asylum cases
which I think account and you can
correct me Lieutenant for eight out of
the ten uh you know migrants who make
their way here uh to say nothing of the
godaways I don't know what those numbers
are but Asylum seems to be the sort of
the card by which they they try to get
not only to to get access to the United
States but in there I stay in the United
States what do you think of that
right and that's the issue right now
that the fact that the Asylum claim is
being abused illegal immigrants are
circumventing the legal immigration
process by claiming Asylum when they get
when they reach the border and the fact
that the federal government has allowed
that have allowed an open border policy
that's why we continue seeing large
groups of urban games coming across and
they're going to continue coming across
just as long as the federal government
continues to have an open border policy
and the fact that they're busting and
flying these immigrants to their
destination so that's the issue right
there the fact that the remain in Mexico
policy was a very effective tool and
what it did was it would slow down Mass
migration it would keep the immigrants
that were seeking Asylum to keep them in
Mexico so they could hear their Asylum
cases there was a more controlled
situation right now it's out of control
and the reason why I say that is because
you're having 1500 to 2 000 immigrants
come across these smaller border
communities a day that's not sustainable
that's unacceptable and that's why there
needs to be a more effective policy put
in place to help slow down this Mass
migration that we're seeing on these
border communities yeah because as you
pointed out once they get over and with
that Asylum claim they stay around and
there's a legal process that facilitates
that sometimes for years to come uh of
course thank you right finish that
thought I'm sorry sir
no no I was going to say I mean you
can't blame these immigrants for making
this journey right because they're being
encouraged so of course they're going to
make this journey they're going to
continue coming because they see friends
and families that have made this journey
and they've been released to the country
so they're going to continue doing so
until actually there's some action put
in place yeah as you pointed out say
Asylum keep saying Asylum that's the
ticket hi winner Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now